PROFESSOR: In order
to anchor the class,
and provide an application
that is at the same time
realistic, but not
overly complex,
we chose to participate in
the 2016 CANSAT competition.
And CANSAT is just what
the name stands for.
It's the design of
a satellite, that
fits into a can,
that is launched,
not into space,
but at relatively
high altitude with a
sounding rocket, essentially.
And so the CANSAT
competition has
been run for about 20 years.
It's quite well
known, and there's
teams from all across the
world that participate.
There is now a CANSAT
competition in the US.
There's also a
European version of it.
The goal of the
CANSAT competition,
is for students
to go step by step
through the design process.
The starting point
for the students,
is a set of requirements,
47 requirements that
are given by the
organizers, about what
the particular system has to do.
For example, the CANSAT has to
fit within the payload fairing
of the rocket.
It has to survive the launch.
So a certain number of
g loads and vibrations
have to be survivable
by the payload.
The payload then has to
separate into both the glider
portion, and the
actual container that
contains the payload.
On its way down, the payload has
to fly in a circular pattern,
for about two minutes.
And during the descent, it
has to record temperature
and pressure of the atmosphere.
And you get extra
bonus points if you
record images, and transmit
those images to the ground.
The students who are
responsible for everything
except the rocket itself.
So the design of the glider, the
container, the ground station,
and all the procedures.
So what's interesting about
systems engineering and design,
is that there are
different approaches,
how to tackle the problem.
One is an approach where
you take it step by step,
and you try to basically get
the right answer at every step.
But, at some point you need
to check yourself, as well,
with milestones.
The other approach,
and that's typically
what we call a waterfall,
or stage gate process, which
is what's applied in very
large systems, where it's
too expensive to do
a lot of prototypes,
and you have to get it
right the first time.
The other approach is spiral
development, or agile,
or rapid development, where
you do quick prototypes,
and you learn very quickly,
and iterate your design.
And in some sense, what
we're doing in this class,
is a combination of the two.
What was very
rewarding, is to see
how students ideated
their concepts, always
keeping in mind
the requirements,
and the end goal in mind.
But, also testing those
ideas, either through modeling
and simulation, or with
very simple prototypes that
can be made out of paper.
One team actually produced
a 3D printed version,
of their glider, even
though that wasn't
officially necessary before
the key milestone, which
is the PDR.
And so it was
interesting to see,
how every team approached
it slightly differently.